the Joe Rogan experience football to me
they're not gonna miss a beat you don't
think so nope
well didn't didn't Gavin our governor
say something about football not coming
back he doesn't count when he talked he
doesn't count when you talked to like
Trump and you hear some of these other
people talk like Trump told the NFL the
commissioners like I'm planning for NFL
season to not skip a beat dude you want
to see people piss in America [ __ ] with
football [ __ ] without shoe football or
Georgia football college football see
what happens you think things are bad
now [ __ ] with the college football you
know this is a weird time to because
it's right before the election you know
election comes in November like imagine
if this said this [ __ ] was going on
right now in the elections like next
week god chaos your boy Bernie dropped
out yep it's wrapped by an 18 Trump nope
that's your best that's the guy it shows
you how crazy the system is that they
wanted him that's not his Biden to be
their guy that they don't they can't
admit that he's in cognitive decline I
mean I'm very strange listen I [ __ ] up
all the time I speak for a living I
[ __ ] up all the time
Haydn's but Biden no he [ __ ] up man
you're politician I [ __ ] up all the time
too but we're also talking live for
hours and hours and hours at time if I
had a prepared thing that I was doing
like my stand-up I don't [ __ ] you would
be sharp as [ __ ] if yes having one of
those conversations they're asking you
look if someone wants to ask me
questions about things that I understand
like MMA or like comedy like if you want
to ask me questions about things that I
think about and talk about all the time
you have your black belt and bulls yes I
could talk to you and really clearly
about those things and make a lot of
sense he can't do that about politics
and he's been a politician forever and
that's your [ __ ] he's he's an you know
he's a guy who's suffering he's in
decline and they're gonna try to whale
mountain whoever his VP is whether it's
Kamala Harris or shell Obama baby
whoever it is but that's who you're
voting for
yeah he's mean it's quite sort of like
when Dick Cheney was basically running
the country yeah
George Bush was the present yeah yeah I
don't know we'll see there's no way he
beats Trump he doesn't beat Trump not a
chance no not a chance
especially because of the
timing in this right now we're in the
[ __ ] right we're in the April [ __ ] is
the worst time of the corona a lot of
people are dying there's a slight
drop-off in New York people dying less
today than yesterday slight drop off
yesterday from the day before so things
are looking pretty good cowboy it's
gonna be yeah California looking very
good right yeah we're crushing it very
good so and then and so and then you go
June July August hopefully everything's
up and running again economy starts
coming back on track Trump makes a
couple of great speeches but Biden is
more in decline it's not gonna get
better no those two faceoff Trump's
gonna light him up like economy Central
Roast
he's already dismissing him sleepy Biden
he's like but he's saying like someone
said Biden said this he was he did first
of all he didn't write that was
Democratic operative he probably doesn't
even know what it says he's gonna
destroy him gonna kill him man I mean
it's such an easy target
it's like Mike Tyson versus a
three-year-old it's true it really is
it's it's it's a terrible fight
I thought Bernie had a legit chance
Bernie had a legit chance he had a legit
chance because there's a lot of people
that are in the middle that are you know
a lot of people that are casually
acquainted with politics that would
listen to his message of doing good for
the working class I think you helped out
with more people I think you made them
human we is on here I was like oh I like
that guy would you have buy it or not no
really no oh man what if he was like
this awesome dude well I'm just really
nervous onstage I'm saying just drops
knowledge no he never was like that
that's the thing if you go back and
listen to him from when he was younger
he was whip smart very smart guy very
very clear sure all those very clear
talk now this is this is a sign of
decline it's it is what it is
you wouldn't have monitored open
conversation time with all that [ __ ]
that Bernie Sanders thing was such a
bummer why because he turned all this
stuff that I didn't stand up and like
things that have said drunken sod cast
and put it in quotes as if I'm a
homophobe or a transfer bore a racist or
they just lied to make it look like
Bernie was supporting some right-wing
person what meanwhile
I've never never been right-wing my life
but also those people don't matter
but it didn't matter as much as it made
me feel like this is a dirty business
like I don't want to be a part of your
dirtiest business there it's it's
they're trying to change people's
opinions with deception it's not like
they're trying to tell you how good
their guy is they're using deception
yeah they're using [ __ ] it's sleazy
its sleazy it's a sleazy business it's
not a meritocracy after Bernie came on
to two other politicians reach out oh
yeah oh yeah sure a lot yeah and they
denied it too I got emails ya know a lot
of them will they reached out to the
publicist but I'm not interested in look
I'm only interested in interviewing
people that I thought were interesting
that I was interested in like Andrew
yang answer sitting that guy like him -
I like him oh my god I love tulsi
gabbard
I just think she - you know she's so
dangerous to those people that they just
they wouldn't want they were trying
changing the rules to keep her from
debating after she sank Kamala Harris
they like this lady's too dangerous
[Applause]